so und jetzt mal eine echte überraschung
meine damen und herren horst seehofer
ist plötzlich feminist also quasi der
horse ist jetzt nämlich doch dafür das
frauenfeindliche gewalttaten bei uns
gezielt erfasst werden kann bis jetzt
als motiv in unseren polizeistatistiken
nicht vor
warum seinen meinungsumschwung
vielleicht weil nächste woche
weltfrauentag ist
vielleicht hat aber auch einfach mal
kolleginnen im bundestag gefragt was die
so viel fanpost kriegen
ich zitiere eine kleine auswahl von über
hunderten kommentaren die meist von
hasserfüllten männern dann dumm wie die
sau die alte da zuckt die faust also uns
ja alles entsetzt opfer
du wirst in flammen aufgehen du dumme
uhren wird vergewaltigt und entsorgt die
türken moore dragster was ist eigentlich
aus dem guten alten frau roth ich bin
inhaltlich nicht ihrer meinung geworden
einfach nur ekelhaft ärgerlich dass das
neue gesetz zur bekämpfung von
hasskriminalität immer noch im bundesrat
fest hängt meine frauen hat ist
natürlich kein neues phänomen aber die
enthemmung nimmt in jedem fall zu und
besonders gefährlich ist es in den
eigenen vier wänden ja alle 33 minuten
erlebt eine frau in deutschland
häusliche gewalt alle 33 minuten im
schnitt wird jeden zweiten bis dritten
tag eine vom partner oder ex-partner
getötet und das betrifft alle
gesellschaftsschichten und kulturkreise
insgesamt registrierte das
bundeskriminalamt im jahr 2017 fast 139
1000 betroffene von partnerschafts
gewalt
fast 100 14.000 davon waren frauen
das sind 82 prozent und ich sag mal so
der lockdown macht das sicher nicht
besser
merke gerade ist ein ganz schwieriges
comedy thema zieht ein total runter kann
man nicht mal irgendwas aufmunterndes
zeigen geht das
[Applaus]
si
wrestling ist fake die hatten nur so
getan als ob er gegen eine frau verliert
schade und ähnlich wie bei der rassismus
debatte findet auch beim thema
frauenhass natürlich die typische opfer
umkehr statt
schon das wort feminismus macht manche
männer sehr aggressiv fühlen sich direkt
bedroht sie können ja auch spaß mal ins
forum unter einem beliebigen artikel
über das gendern gucken und auf
plattformen gerettet oder vor chain wird
frauenhass geradezu zelebriert zb von
sogenannten in fels in monterrey celebes
also sehr vereinfacht gesagt von typen
die keine abkriegen ja nicht zu
verwechseln mit der sogenannten mendoza
on way bewegung das sind männer die
sagen wir könnten jeder haben aber wir
wollen nicht weil frauen einen nur
ausnutzen und böse sind und früher war
sowieso alles besser
früher vor dem feminismus sie meine 1955
gab es für jeden mann eine frau egal
bieten attraktiv der mann war
heutzutage wollen alle frauen nur die
gut aussehenden und interessanten ja
klar ja alle männer die eine frau haben
sehen aus wie brad pitt und da will ich
mich gar nicht ausnehmen der richtigen
beleuchtung nach kinder war das schön
1955 oder einfachen antrag stellen beim
frauen zu ordnungsamt zwei tage später
kam er mit der post ja das klingt absurd
aber tatsächlich denken in sales sie
hätten als man quasi ein recht auf sex
das wäre lustig wenn ihr nicht auch
schlimmste gewalt fantasie hingegen
frauen austauschen würden frage warum
gibt es keine weiblichen inselgruppen
die männer hass verbreiten ganz einfach
erst wenn männer lange keine freundin
hatten oder noch nie werden so sauer auf
die frau an sich und mühlen das internet
mit wut zu frauen ohne partner kuscheln
sich auf dem sofa ein futtern schokoeis
gucken in der linz strom und stellen
sich die eine frage auf die single
männer nicht kommen würden liegt
vielleicht auch ein bisschen an mir
stellt sich nie die frage toxische
männlichkeit dauer aggression wir sind
gefangene des testosterons da hätte man
schon vor jahrhunderten daran arbeiten
müssen
jungs werden voll adlers weil wir teile
abgekriegt haben wisst ihr was uns
ersparen könnte ein schuldenstaat und
wisst ihr was wir dann anzünden
duftkerzen lavendel duftkerzen gute idee
übrigens nicht nur die insel träumt vom
großen rollback von der rückkehr der
50er und der gottgewollten
rollenverteilung so was gehört natürlich
auch zur dna der afd
die alternative für deutschland stemmt
sich gegen die feminisierung
deutschlands denn sie wissen ja das
große problem ist dass deutschland und
europa ihre männlichkeit verloren haben
ich sage wir müssen unseren männlichkeit
wieder in beckeln wenn wir unsere
männlichkeit wiederentdecken werden wir
man habe gelernt wenn es mit der man
heftigkeit nicht mehr so klappt da kann
man sich doch pillen im internet
bestellen ich schickte man link unserem
ähnlichkeit ist bedroht von allen seiten
manchmal bedrohend wehrmänner sie sogar
selber thomas deutscher vize chef der
jungen alternative bayern kämpft deshalb
bei facebook gegen onanie er wirklich er
schreibt sie dort masturbation sollte
generell eingestellt werden da sie einen
der schöpferischen energie viele
nährstoffe und männlicher kraft beraubt
deutscher ist damit ein vertreter der
sogenannten low fat bewegung keine
pornos keine masturbation alleine dafür
müsste die afg vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet werden aber klappt ja erstmal
nicht hier neuer wahlspot im namen des
volkes
deutsche männer in termes fähigen alter
verschwende ich es enthält schöpferische
energie nährstoffe und männlicher kraft
verwandeln das taschentuch nicht den
magen aller schatten und reißt euch am
riemen aber passt die nicht an aktion
kraft durch keine freunde deutscher
sagen nur den damen
ja am ende ist das ganze wahrscheinlich
auch nur ein vogel vix der geschichte
tatsächlich hat der einzug der afg in
den bundestag 2017 das klima da
nachhaltig verändert man könnte auch
sagen das biotop ist nicht mehr dasselbe
herzlich willkommen zu tera mix der
bundestag wird zum party hügel mit
carolin kebekus
ja liebe naturfreund in später debatte
im deutschen bundestag unten leitet
gleich claudia roth die sitzung und dann
werden wir ein spannendes phänomen
erleben
sobald eine frau spricht wird es
schlagartig laut im afg gehege direkt 30
dezibel mehr gucken sie mal zwei alte
männchen plustern sich auf und pieksen
mit dem finger in die luft rechts
übrigens ein silberrücken der bald von
der herde zurückgelassen wird klassische
dominanz kiste
du bist nur eine grüne frau wir haben
einen penis
egal ob die ochsen frische in australien
oder die afc im bundestag immer wieder
faszinierend wie so eine invasive arten
ganzes biotop umkrempelt meistens nicht
zum guten
wir wissen dass sie insbesondere
kolleginnen die in ihrer nähe sitzen
beleidigen so dass die kolleginnen das
hören ist aber nicht im protokoll
aufgenommen werden kann ist schön
genau deshalb sitze ich ja hier oben in
sicherer entfernung jetzt im frühjahr
sind die besonders aggressiv wegen
brunftzeit fellwechsel sowas verstehe
tatsächlich gab es ja gerade eine
umfrage im bundestag und da haben
politikerinnen aller parteien also außer
dem paar frauen der kfd von ständigen
beleidigungen und einem klima der
einschüchterung berichtet meine das kann
man doch nicht hinnehmen nein natürlich
nicht
es gibt abgeordnete die trauen sich hier
abends nicht mehr allein auf die flure
ist kein witz
jetzt noch lauter jetzt spricht eine
frau mit migrationshintergrund
es ist ja so hier steht eine art
evolutionär mit dem rücken zur wand
alles verändert sich frauen reicht es
nicht mehr einen guten sauerbraten zu
machen und sich regelmäßig deutsche
kinder raus zu quetschen
dies macht denen angst deswegen auch der
kampf gegen die quote als nächstes hören
wir auch schon sagen migranten im moment
mal wenn es eine frauenquote gibt da
muss nicht migranten quote geben und
dann sagen andere teile der gesellschaft
auch mit gleicher berechtigung
behinderte der moment mal da muss eine
behindertenquote geben
haben sie es gesehen in seinen augen
hatte panik wenn du eine frau reinlässt
in die chefetage zack stehen drei
minuten später die ausländer und die
behinderten vor der tür
es sind frauen jetzt eine minderheit das
hat er doch nicht gemeint minderwertig
und faulheit dir super afd tipp für
quotenfrauen ich muss ihnen einfach
sagen sie müssen einfach mal
mitarbeiters probieren die männer die in
diesen positionen sind haben sich das
hochgearbeitet
mit ungeheurer energie und wenn sie das
gleiche tun würden sie das auch schaffen
ach ja ich möchte mich jetzt eigentlich
tierisch aufregen aber selbst dafür bin
ich als frau leider zu verhalten sekunde
was gibt's ja gar nicht das können sie
jetzt nicht sehen aber ein kfd menschen
hat es ganz allein auf die empore
geschafft kommt auf mich zu wahnsinn ich
war noch nie so nah dran
okay das wird mir jetzt noch ein
bisschen zu nach mal das
betäubungsgewehr
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mime hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und sie
töten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]